ciao ragazzi niente stavo lavorando sul
cosa sul nuovo video e poi sono messo un
pochino su youtube
ho letto dei messaggi o un po di tempo
che arrivano messaggi che capito
ma che non lo fa pure così perché perché
gli viene spontaneo magari pensa che sei
chissà chi però essendo una persona
qualsiasi volte un pò prima ci rimani
male e oggi è oggi quindi niente un
messaggio video del canale ragazzi non
vedo perché chi c'è chi ce la fa più
cioè io sono gesù normale senso nè che
capito chissà che faccia quindi voce mi
dispiace perché sono tante le persone
che magari mi mandano dei bei messaggi
nelle cose carine e cioè che non
vogliono deludermi solo che c'è che
faccio in uk non sono forte nel senso è
che posso stare lì e se far finta di non
leggere le cose perché un elenco delle
trend so aiuto aiuto domani perché così
ci tenevo a farvi vedere questa cosa o
che dire
magari qualcuno sarà contento che sto
così c'è non vorrei che voglio essere in
qualche modo in grado capito perché io
le adoro le persone
però anche se solo poker interno sono
forte mi dispiace e quindi ci siamo così
a ringraziarvi per avermi fatto sentire
almeno qualcuno
e quindi niente volevo dire un'ultima
cosa
grazie
calcio bello
ciascuno si gira niente siamo troppi mi
spiace che per per mio fratello che che
appena aspetto telecamera del backstage
e uno che per ficcare su mediche uno già
detto che la juve non rischi di chopin
persone fantastiche avete riempito tanto
esco da visitare l'alto che l'ippica
sarà presente dato tanto esco da questa
esperienza
io amo le persone
ricominciamo incominciato a straparlare
dall'energia della ragazza della del
grande fratello 1 esko non lo vedo
io so se adesso se questa era capito già
quello parla tragico ti aspetto e quindi
lo chiudo l'aiuto domani cioè il passo
del senso
meno male che è finita perché non dei
dirtti un pazzo questa parte scusatemi